timer's content calendar is going to be
one coaching session a week and one
Master Class A Week those can all be
batched right so the coaching sessions
all happen on one day and the master
classes can all happen on one day and
that might just be one full day a month
to do both
you're doing four coaching sessions half
an hour 45 minutes each an hour if you
want and then you're doing four master
classes it's a lot of um energy to do
but whether it's one full day of filming
or two half days of filming this is
usually what I'm working with big names
like talents time is always the hardest
thing to get a hold of so when you can
chunk it it's a lot easier than just
coming to the studio make one video and
leave but you can make enough content
for twice a week videos
in the equivalent of one full day per
month we don't want to only talk to our
3 000 subscribers we want to reach
people who've never heard of timer
before this is how we're going to grow
we expect these videos not to do super
well but because it helps me grow my
business then it's worth doing
I've got a YouTube channel which is
about how to scale your business
basically
um by becoming the CEO of your business
so how do you understand how to run your
business using strategy using systems
and processes Finance so it's it's a
more sort of broad view in terms of how
to grow your business it took us about a
year to get to a thousand subscribers
but actually it's taken us about five
months to get to three thousand and
we're scaling pretty fast I'd love to
see how we can sort of take it even
further faster hopefully what's the
service or product that you're selling
we sell a 12-month program called the
five-star program
um and it's basically for business
owners that are earning over six figures
so this is not about how to find your
niches or not early on this is about
you've got a business model you know it
works now how do you actually scale it
and
um this is a 12-month program which is a
mix of online learning Consulting
coaching kind of hybrid put together and
it really takes the business owners to
to that next level
I'd love to talk to you about my story
but I'll leave that for another time
because it you it'll put things into
context and why I'm doing this
cool I mean I'm excited to dive deeper
and learn from yeah this theme is is you
know content calendar and structure what
what are you thinking through for your
content calendar
what we've been doing previously is
doing a video every
um I've been trying to be consistent to
do a video a week but actually in the
last year it's kind of become more one
video every two weeks but I've hired now
as we're scaling I've hired a Content
team an editor in-house and we're trying
to go for two videos a week one of them
which is a kind of a normal 10 to 12
minute episode that sort of takes one of
the topics within business like systems
how do you look at your systems or
strategy or whatever
um and then we want to have a second one
which is more of a quick fire maybe
three to four minute q a so we get
people within the community tab to ask
us questions and I just sort of fire it
and my team have decided to call it Tama
time because it kind of like has that
whole sort of hammer time thing but um
yeah I don't know um but yeah so so
that's where we're at so we're aiming to
try and do two videos a week from from
March that's that's the plan
and is it is it coaching that you want
to sell or is it the the programs and
the systems and the
it's the programs and the systems I I
think so we're not aiming we're aiming
more at the really small sort of
solopreneur businesses who have got
maybe about two to three outsourced
people but they really want to
understand how to grow a business
um I've grown uh just just as a quick
background I've grown businesses to 100
million dollars and I've also failed
catastrophically where I've had two and
a half million dollars in debt
personally and having to bail my
business partner out of prison in Dubai
um not our fault but that's another
story yeah so I think what I was looking
for at the time I know it's an
incredibly saturated Market
um there's a lot of people out there
trying to help people grow businesses
um but I wanted to come from it from a
different perspective in terms of really
how do you actually integrate and
embrace failure because things go wrong
in your business how do you really look
at it as becoming the CEO of your own
business so I'm not really focused on
the marketing side which is where a lot
of business people sort of like you know
gurus online at the moment are doing
this is more of a an overall strategic
view of how do you actually learn how to
run your business so how do you look at
the strategy how do you look at the
systems Finance budgeting and being able
to understand that in a bite-sized way
where it's not for large size
organizations but we're kind of bringing
it down to the small business owner and
yeah uh as we scale we want to make sure
that the program the group program for
us is what scales otherwise just
one-to-one coaching is not scalable for
us
um 90 of our
sign ups in January which is really
surprising ninety percent
um
came from the YouTube channel
organically from people all over the
world
um we were expecting the YouTube channel
to sort of really kick in for us three
to five years time to start generating
Revenue
um and we were kind of looking at other
ways but actually it's just gone much
much faster than what we had anticipated
and it's fantastic so we're trying to
keep up at the moment that's great I
think look is this the channel here yeah
yeah that's the one yeah we're going
through a thumbnail change at the moment
where we're gonna do less yellow but um
but yeah that's the one and as you can
see we've we've got to about 3 000
subscribers
two of those thousand in the last four
to five months
um and and you'll see that if you scroll
down a little bit you'll see some of the
videos the popular ones uh if you saw by
popular rather than by
um by um release date you'll see that
we've got some which are doing really
well at the moment whatever you want to
make money doing showing the process as
you think through content calendar right
I guess the theme for today whatever you
want to make money doing show me the
process of you doing it and so this is a
great example of you got 90 of your
leads from YouTube and you've got 3 000
subscribers yeah you know like you don't
need to have a 10 million subscriber
Channel you're targeting a specific
Niche So for anybody who's targeting if
you were targeting how to make your
first hundred dollars as an entrepreneur
now we're going super broad but you want
the people who are already six figures
which is not most entrepreneurs
right people like they would love to be
making six figures uh and now helping
them become seven eight figure
entrepreneurs now it's a really it's a
niche now obviously it could be more
than 3 000 subscribers but it's a great
example of if you're making really
targeted content how it can lead to
growth for your business
um if we're looking at
here's a good little example to to start
with
if you want to sell so you know what
what is Tamer trying to sell is trying
to sell his his services to help CEOs
grow organizations
um
you have a mix of you just talking to
camera right looks like into some funnel
elements in there and then you
taking questions and doing Q a off of
their
like you're responding to their comments
right yeah as as the last one you see
here yeah that's that's exactly yeah
so this is great and for anybody who is
a coach an expert a thought leader
whether whether Tamara wants to to sell
coaching services or not showing that he
knows
people's challenges and how to help them
through can be great content
I would love to see this be a video of
you actually helping people
as opposed to just one
yeah do you mean actually have them on
the call on the video itself live okay
yeah that might be a really good idea
yeah yeah because and and I mean you've
seen this the question that people come
in with is very rarely the question they
actually need help with and it's hard to
give a deep answer on like a one-liner
question without having context about
their business so you can give a
standard answer
hey Tamara what are the what are the
three ways to grow my business to a
million dollars you know you can give
your standard answer but if they're
right there in front of you you'll
actually dissect what their real problem
is and help them through it
which then
because you know what you're doing
really showcases oh my gosh just Hammer
guy is legit not just another guy on
YouTube making content telling me how to
grow a business right so it's a much
more
specific answer and also if you can get
entrepreneurs on who are
in your target market
as you light up their eyes
then other people watch you and say oh
this guy is
this guy's maybe for me I wanna can I
hire him does he have a program does he
have Services right
um so there's a couple ways to do it you
can do it based off of who's on your
email list already
you can do it who's following you on
other social channels and offer it to
them you could do it as a reward for
people who are in like how many people
are in your course or you're training
right now
so
um last month we signed up 20. by the
way it's it's um a 12 000 uh program and
we haven't done a trip by they come
straight in from YouTube into this
program which is phenomenal phenomenal
yeah so as a bonus
and is it is an annual like is it 12 000
a year twelve thousand one hour it's 12
000 a year yeah so it's for the 12 month
program it's 12 000 a year or twelve
hundred a month if they pay monthly uh
okay in installments but yeah so you
know 20 people it's it's a fantastic
start you could offer to all 20 of them
that as part of it as part of their
first year they get a half an hour
coaching session
with hammer that would go on a really
good idea yeah yeah actually that's a
really good idea and I hadn't thought of
that that's a really good idea so you
get content
now they may not want to make it public
but that's that's the caveats like hey
this this is going to be public on our
YouTube channel so that other people can
learn who are in the same situation as
you and it's a chance to talk about your
program without talking about your
program right yeah yeah you know here's
John from our coaching or from our from
our program and he's a you know six
figure entrepreneur what's John gonna
say John say oh my God Tamara I love the
program so much it's been fantastic
right now you got an advocate inside the
video and then you say hey John how can
I help what are you struggling with
right now what problem are you going
through and he's going to tell you
something and you're going to be able to
help him right you don't need a brief
and a pre-interview because you've seen
all the challenges you know what people
are going through yeah yeah
so you know back to Michael's original
you know Post in the Facebook group
about content calendar what is what are
you trying to sell and then show me the
process of you doing it
so pammer's trying to sell his his
program it's great that he can answer
these questions then this could be a
great series but even better is showing
you with somebody who's actually in the
program and taking it to the next level
because your stuffed Hammer is about
next level thinking not beginner level
thinking
yeah yeah you have to dive into what are
the next level problems that people are
struggling with
yeah and that makes a lot of sense
because if you actually go to the home
page um without running the the trailer
um if you pause that yeah if you have a
look at the one immediately the business
masterclass
um that was much much longer video it's
an hour and that's actually the one
that's driven us the most sales
um oh for sure what I did was actually
walk through the process and I gave
three case studies within within the
program actually in terms of what it was
and I I didn't want to put this master
class behind a an email wall like a lot
of people do I thought let me put that
there and then if they want to download
the slides then they can come and sign
up and and sort of get on our email list
um and what you're saying actually just
takes that to the next level where it's
like okay now not just are we talking
about these case studies but they're
live with us and we're sort of having
that one-to-one interaction so I really
like that
yeah and I mean everybody here you guys
can all do the same thing take the
people who are in your programs reward
them for being in your programs they're
going to feel amazing like oh my God I
get a one-on-one time with Tamara as
well to ask whatever questions I've got
on my mind and the only caveat is going
to be on YouTube like some people may
say no but most people see it as a as a
amazing benefit that otherwise you can't
hire Tammer
you can't work with him one-on-one this
is the only way to get access to him get
your question answered
um
longer videos for sure
10 minutes plus but the biggest growth
category is one to three hours so we've
talked about this it's your first time
here we've talked about this before
um people are going to learn and for all
of you so you look at Tamer if I want to
grow my business I'm a six figure
business I might get the seven figures
where am I going to learn
you know who am I talking to maybe I
have a mentor probably not you know I'm
not going to the library like where am I
going to go to learn I'm going to
YouTube and I want to learn and I'm
going to YouTube not just to get I don't
I don't want just a quick hit of
motivation to tell me you can do this
just keep going don't quit you're like
that's great that's Instagram
I'm going to YouTube to actually figure
out how do I do this thing what are the
steps that I need to take and so if you
make an hour-long video I'd be doing
regular master classes
if you can you know this is now a bigger
time commitment but people are going to
learn
uh and so the longer the video again the
biggest growth we're seeing is one to
three hour so
I would say 10 minutes at a minimum so
these are going to be really hard to
ever do anything with in terms of
picking up and taking taking off yeah
these ones were actually pulled out of a
longer video and we just made them into
smaller bite-sized videos but with
regards to what you were saying a lot of
people were saying to us to make shorter
videos and then when we did the master
class which is an hour and five minutes
YouTube promoted that video more than
any any other of our videos so the video
has actually been out for about two
months now and it's got 2 000 views on
there whereas even the ones that have
got to about 13 000 views
um it took about a year to get to get to
that level and this is by far in terms
of how how long it's been released and
what YouTube is doing in terms of The
Impressions it's showing it actually is
pushing it out even more
um so that completely validates what
you're saying where actually we've we've
seen that firsthand that the longer
videos are the ones that are getting us
more views
YouTube loves long content YouTube's
goal is to keep you on YouTube for as
long as possible now to your credit
you're you're holding people right like
they're it's not just an hour-long video
just to have an hour long video if you
weren't holding attention and giving
value in this video I mean I haven't
seen it but you know you're holding
people's attention or YouTube wouldn't
be promoting you but given the choice
between holding attention on a long
video and holding attention a short
video YouTube always wants to go a long
video inside of thought leadership and
education so these videos I wouldn't
remove them but they're mostly dead like
the the chances of ranking for a one
minute video is is like unless you're a
Star Wars trailer or something crazy
you're just not gonna win in 2022 with
it
um
so yeah more of these if you can and
there's there looks like there's a lot
of production quality on here as well
like Simpsons and uh you know cartoons
and stuff which is fine
um I'd even look at dropping the
production quality if it means getting
more videos out because it's quality of
thought more than quality of production
because you have knowledge that people
don't have
thank you yeah that and and we're
getting comments on the channel now when
people come in I think that's the thing
because even if you see the master class
there's a there's obviously the initial
drop of people just not staying on but
once people do it's a flat curve all the
way through the whole hour
um and and and that means that people
that have stuck around are sticking
around and then they're commenting and
saying this is really good how is this
channel not even bigger than it is and
then they you can see them commenting on
other videos and binge watching the
channel and I think that that's why
YouTube has begun to start showing it to
even more people
um and that's why we've kind of grown in
the last five months quite quite rapidly
yeah so if this was if all your content
was like that now I know that's a high
bar compared to making a four minute
video especially on your time so but if
90 or 80 of your leads are coming from
YouTube
it could be a worthwhile investment of
your time to spend a little more on
making content
um a lot of those can be batched so
again content calendar if if timer's
content calendar is going to be one
coaching session uh a week and one
Master Class A Week those can all be
batched right so the coaching sessions
all happen on one day
and the master classes can all happen on
one day and that might just be one full
day
a month to do both
you're doing four coaching sessions half
an hour 45 minutes each an hour if you
want and then you're doing four master
classes it's a lot of um energy
to do
but whether it's one full day of filming
or two half days of filming this is
usually when I'm working with big names
like talents time is always the hardest
thing to get a hold of
so when you can chunk it it's a lot
easier than just come into the studio
make one video and leave but you can
make enough content for twice a week
videos
in the equivalent of one full day per
month
for the channel yeah this is something
that we've struggled with at the moment
because that's that's been that's been
the thing is that we've not been able to
push out content as consistently as as
we'd like so being able to come and
batch batch record these things I think
will help us a lot
yeah like you and your team you say hey
on the first Thursday of every month
we're filming
yeah and
I mean for me it's every Tuesday where
I'm filming content and we have one
giant filming day once a month and then
we have smaller the other Tuesdays are
smaller filming days but every Tuesday
I'm making content and the team gets it
ready for me so like your team was
booking the calls it's not you saying
hey do you want to come on a call with
me at this time right team gets all that
lined up you just have to show up and
for most people that's the most fun
you know if you just show up and you're
helping and there's a client in front of
you who really needs your knowledge and
you're giving them a lot of value it's
the time flies going through that kind
of content as well
um
yeah and then the master class and we
can we can do a deep dive on a later
session like actually look at your
analytics
um
if it's dropping off a cliff at the
beginning we we you know we it's great
that you're holding people but now how
do we learn from that so that it's not
dropping off as big a cliff ongoing how
do we make our intro better
um and that's going to be super common
for everybody if you look at your
retention curves the first minute it's
going to be pretty poor
because people don't know you
like the people who know Tamara is gonna
love his stuff and can't wait for the
next one but we don't want to only talk
to our 3 000 subscribers we want to
reach people who've never heard of timer
before like this is how we're going to
grow so when they see you and they don't
know who you are it's harder to keep
their attention versus somebody who
already loves you
um so you know we can we can dive in and
look at you know retention strategies
and all that later but for Content I
think that's a good one for you
um you're coaching people
who are in your program or thinking
about being in your program uh who've
downloaded your triage quiz you know
like you might run out of people if you
only have 20 right now in the program
if everybody says yes that's 20 weeks of
content that's not bad actually you know
it's almost half the year
that's not bad if they all say yes
uh and if you need more people people
who filled out your triage quiz
um you can also bring them back for
round two
you know like if it's six months later
they have new problems
I mean that's the official that's the
benefit of it you know so you you can
you can rotate people and have them come
back six months later that's fine too
um
guests so this is another interesting
one for
content strategy hopefully everybody can
learn from so is this guy who is this
guy that you brought on
actually he interviewed me and we just
had highlights of it on that way but um
we have been considering doing a sort of
um guest session where we bring people
in and we interview them and it's
related to somebody who's grown a
business but actually has had struggles
as well because what we want to do is we
want to highlight that business is all
is not all Glitz and glamor
um it's it's how you sort of get through
and the learning lessons so we've been
considering this and I wasn't sure
whether that would fit
within this channel would it need a
separate Channel and and that was kind
of one of the questions I was going to
ask um at a different sort of date but
uh
I don't know well I mean it's helpful to
the discussion and I know we're spending
a lot of time on you today but we
haven't seen you before and it's also
great to uh it's content calendar so
fits the theme
um
it really depends on the goal of the
channel I don't I wouldn't recommend
starting a second Channel when you're
not like you're still getting your feet
on consistency on the first one
right so yeah I wouldn't worry about
that yet does it fit into the main
Channel It's really more about what do
you hope to accomplish because if you're
trying to sell more people into your
program
then it's much more about you being the
guy I want your methodology I want to
learn from you and how you overcame
these problems and you're the expert
that I'm signing up to listen to not how
you interviewed like I'm not buying your
course or your membership because you
had
some big entrepreneur on and you
interviewed him like you're the Larry
King or the whoever
um so if if it's some big name maybe
that gets you new eyeballs on a channel
like if you had whoever uh you had
garyvee or Grant Cardone or or someone
who's got a big audience you're gonna
interview Oprah about this awesome
because then that brings a lot of new
eyeballs but if it's if it's just an
entrepreneur that we has had a lot of
success but we've never heard of which
is most people like most entrepreneurs
have had big success you wouldn't
recognize their names
yeah because they haven't made a point
of getting out on social that probably
doesn't help your Channel
um and your business grow that much
yeah I agree I agree
so like yeah it's behind the con if it's
fun uh great
um it can be great Biz Dev so again for
everybody here too if you think content
calendar if there's somebody who you
really want to meet Tamara it could be a
good Biz partner for you or referral for
you or connection for you
it's a lot easier to build the
relationship by doing an interview with
them to say hey come and be a guest on
my show and you're they're finding them
and giving them all this accolades right
and then it leads to a connection and
hopefully some business afterwards so
that could be great
there's a reason to do it besides the
growth of the channel
right that it carries a business Roi for
you so that could be like okay we expect
these videos not to do super well
but because it helps me grow my business
then it's worth doing
this is a fun topic this is something
that I obsess over how do we get our one
minute audience retention it's it's a
super geeky topic uh of all the things
that um that I
try to teach when I'm doing
presentations uh this is the only thing
that I get technical with the audience
retention curve the audience retention
curve the audience retention curve like
remember this thing pay attention to it
look at your data because it's easy to
get lost in YouTube data but this one is
super super important understand that
YouTube's goal is to keep you on YouTube
right that's their goal so the more
you're keeping people on YouTube the
more they're going to promote your
videos and so many people focus on
the entire video which is important but
what often happens is if you get the
first minute down really well and you're
keeping people for for that attention
they'll watch the rest of the video If
you go look at most of your curves you
you'll see it's mostly flat or just
slowly sloping down but that first mint
is where we tend to lose people so
people are often shocked if you go look
at your own stats people are often
shocked at how poorly their videos are
doing in that first minute so today
that's what we are talking about let me
share my screen boom specific strategies
that boost viewer retention I'm excited
okay let's dive in so the goal
the goal is 70 at one minute this is uh
this is a really hard number to hit
especially consistently nobody hits this
number consistently not not inside
thought leadership I don't do it nobody
that I've looked at does it
um
it's really really really really hard
and I've looked at everybody's Channel
at least the big Channel since I thought
leadership but it's still the goal it's
still still that elusive here's what
we're working towards and this curve
that's the honest attention curve you'll
see this on every single video this is
free
um inside YouTube Studio product uh you
can get lost again in data but this one
is super super important and it'll show
you basically where people are falling
off so wherever you know here whatever
happened here that sucks then that was
good then that sucks and then that
sucked at the end and then these little
Peaks here this is what we're going to
share to social content right we've
talked about this in the past but uh
just quick refresh
this slide is one of you guys may have
seen in the past one minute retention
this video we did had 73 at one minute
has almost three million views on the
channel and this is what a typical Curve
will look like right it should be slowly
just declining over time and it's this
part that we're really trying to
optimize in this first minute trying to
make sure that we're keeping it not that
big a slump so you'll always get this
you'll always get this little drop here
at the beginning the key is not making
that drop and losing 40 of our audience
which happens to a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot of channels
so here's something that we haven't
talked about yet that I wanted to just
bring up on your radar tubebuddy has a
tool that I requested uh and help them
build called the retention analyzer now
it's a little buggy and they don't
update it very often because they
basically made it for me and and some of
the people who like using it
um but it's not part of their core thing
that like everybody's using it for but
if you are using tubebuddy for split
testing right now
two buddies of tool that we use we've
done over 10 000 split tests on the
channel thumbnails titles Etc
if you're on that program you're on that
package I think that's 50 bucks a month
something like that it's not it's not
crazy expensive they have something
built in here as well called retention
analyzer
so if you go to your tubebuddy you click
on data and insights on the left and
then scroll down to retention analyzer
it'll pull up your most recent it's not
all it says all videos it's not it's
going to be your most recent I think 50
videos and then you can sort by
retention at various time stamps so I'd
say with sort by the one minute Mark and
see where you're at and you can just get
a sense of how well you're doing which
videos are performing well which videos
aren't uh just to give you a sense you
know instead of having to Go videos one
by one by one by one by one this will
help you give get an over overall sense
and see where you're doing well and
which videos uh are not doing so well
and we need to make a few adjustments to
help your channel grow so I would
definitely check that out if you're if
you're on the package for the split
testing you're already paying for this
anyway so you might as well take a look
and see which videos are performing well
and where there's some room for
improvement okay so today we're going to
talk about a lot of the dues but before
that I want to talk about some of the
don't do so this is the things you want
to avoid when you're starting your video
okay these will these will destroy your
audience retention curve
intros hi I'm Evan and I XYZ right no
intros live stream welcomes are the
worst you know a live stream
the first couple minutes usually really
really really suck on the live stream
you're welcoming people you're saying hi
you're asking about their day that's
great for a live stream environment but
not great for a YouTube video again
we're trying to assume the people who
are watching our videos don't know who
we are that's our target audience we're
not talking to our subscribers we're
talking to our non-subscribers this is
the first time they're seeing you so we
want to hit them with something that's
going to be really powerful don't do a
Sizzle reel
you getting out of your car looking
fancy or on stage looking like a special
person like none of that stuff really
brings in a lot of attention uh call to
actions we don't want call to action at
the beginning because we lose people
you'll see a big drop in your honest
attention curve
um and then Audio Only Audio Only is
really hard we're I'm working on a
couple strategies actually with some
podcasters like how do I turn my podcast
into a YouTube video when I don't have
video when it's just an audio stream and
every time I've seen it it's really
tanked but if you can make it visually
appealing I think there's a case I think
there just hasn't been a lot of
innovation on the podcast inside for how
you can play with visuals so these are
all the don't Do's don't do any of these
things and if you're looking at your
data and you're seeing that you're
you're at you know 40 retention at one
minute you're probably doing one or
multiple of these and it's not helping
your videos grow
okay so we just finished uh
a breakdown of 990 of our videos this
just happened on Tuesday so what day is
today Thursday so two days ago I haven't
even gone through all the data myself
yet but uh I had one of my guy my I have
a full-time data analyst on my team and
that's what he does is goes and looks
store data and gives us suggestions on
what's working what's not working and
you compiled this giant spreadsheet of
of which videos are popping hard you
know we're at 78 retention at one minute
in which ones
are underperforming and so I'm going to
share with you some of the insights that
we found today which I'm excited because
I didn't even know some of these things
until Tuesday
um having a full-time data analyst
really really helps
uh so I'm excited let's dive in and look
at some of the some of the data Okay so
that first minute again our goal is to
capture attention so multiple camera
angles we found really really has been
helping and this is some of the stuff
that I used to do that I haven't done as
much it's it's shocking when you look at
your data you might find oh something I
was doing back in 2019 is actually
outperforming what I'm doing right now
and all of these numbers are for the
past 90 days on my channel so it's not
lifetime of video this worked I've been
around for 12 years or something so it's
not like this worked back in 2014 and it
doesn't work anymore all the stats is
basically the last 90 days so multiple
camera angles we did four transitions in
the first 15 seconds and that helped
lead to 78 at one minute
okay getting outside
switching up the background having some
color
again this one four transitions in 18
seconds 70 at one minute
so I'm seriously looking at okay what
what can we do besides just using I love
my studio but besides just using the
studio what else could we use where else
could we go now some of this requires
more editing this one is pretty simple
this one even if you're doing it
yourself you could just do different
camera angles
for the intro this is only for the first
minute don't worry about making it
highly produced
um I
value editing but I think ultimately
it's going to be your capabilities to
pull out great information it's going to
carry the day but in that first minute
especially the editing can can make a
difference to hook somebody's attention
so you could do this even if you're
filming on your own but if you have
somebody as a camera operator helping
you you can move the side move around
just have different angles and again
just getting outside if you can if it's
warm we got summer you know right here
so can you do anything outside uh to
just shake up the background just to
make it a little more interesting a
little more appealing
um one hack that Billy Jean loves doing
for his ads if you don't know Billie
Jean he's one of the the experts on on
advertisements so YouTube ads Facebook
ads Etc is go look up in your city what
are the top places that people like to
go to
and then try to film there
so it takes more time uh it takes more
budget it takes it takes a team to maybe
help you but if there's an interesting
background so I'm in Toronto there's you
know the CN tower there's Niagara Falls
there's you know different places but if
you look at the top places people like
to visit and then that happens to be in
your background that could help just get
people interested at the beginning
Fast Cuts so
here's an example where we did 10
transitions in 21 seconds
where we're doing a preview of things to
come and this is something that after
looking at the data on this we're going
to be playing with it instead of longer
clips
doing coming up leading with shorter
Clips but more of them as opposed to
longer more in-depth Clips really that
first minute is people are justifying
their time with you
I don't know who you are I like the
topic do I want to watch this video you
know it's like people will skim an
article before they read it that's
what's happening right now so if you can
give them a chance to skim the video
before they watch it you can hook them
in so this is something when we plan a
lot more with uh we're after seeing this
I just instructed my team hey I want our
next two weeks of videos on the top 10
Channel I want to be doing 10 cuts for
each one and let's see if we can play
this out so think about your own videos
think about your own content uh you
don't have to have 10 rules but how can
you take some of the Highlight moments
and instead of just one or two highlight
moments go for five six seven eight
highlight moments that are in more in
Rapid succession to say okay there's a
lot there's a lot of meat coming up in
this video
I want to watch it
so this this was really mind-blowing for
me this was some experiment we did I
don't know back in 2016 just as a as a
one-off and never went back to it for
whatever reason
like wait a minute that actually worked
let's go back and look at it and you
know when you have 10 000 videos like I
do on my channel uh there's a lot of
data to report to to get some
interesting information so super fast
Cuts I would definitely play with some
of these for your videos
so solo videos
the most important thing is to lead with
a powerful opinion
and the question I always ask people is
what do you believe that others don't
so you're going to make a video on
habits great what do you believe about
habits that other people don't that they
would find weird like I can't believe
you said that
because this is our goal is to hook
somebody in
this is specific for Thought leadership
videos you are a thought leader you are
an expert you know things that other
people don't know that's the whole idea
why am I watching you because you're
going to teach me something so what do
you believe that I don't already know
and that's the first thing that comes
out of your mouth
so you know I've done when I've done my
thought Leadership Academy we'll spend
half a day just working on this stuff
practicing it like writing it down and
then saying it to the camera because
it's really hard
a lot of times it's hard to get out of
our own heads and so imagine what I find
helpful is imagining somebody imagine
one of your clients so Stephen might
imagine an entrepreneur Robert or his
wife might be imagining somebody who's
you know dealing with trauma like you
picture somebody
and then that's the first thing you're
talking to this person
I would always picture this photographer
friend that I knew who always seemed to
struggle could never seem to figure it
out and instead of talking to the camera
like I'm talking to I'm talking to this
guy I'm talking to you
how would he react
um when I had my cameraman uh there was
one of them that uh
always seemed to kind of disagree with
what I said
at the beginning and it's like great
you're perfect so I pitched my first
sentence to him and then I see what his
reaction was and then that would that
would change how it would then pitch my
next sentence right it was like wait
what like perfect I got my first
sentence if you agree with me he's like
okay no I gotta I gotta I gotta change
it up so lead with a powerful opinion
the first thing out of your mouth this
is really hard because again A lot of
times people click record and then they
go back the default to how they've done
it hey welcome back it's Evan like no I
just told you don't do that powerful
opinion first thing out of your mouth
that's that's how we need to lead this
session
um so most important part uh deliver it
with with uh with power as well
so this is where a lot of thought
leaders also struggle is that okay you
finally get the perfect sentence out
but it's not delivered with any
enthusiasm or excitement and this is
from some top people as well who I know
are great speakers they're trying to
memorize that first sentence and then
when they say it the words come out
perfect but there's no emotional
commitment to it
you have to be emotionally connected to
the thing that you're saying as if
somebody is in front of you right now
and they're struggling with that very
thing and they need to hear from you I
know sometimes that's hard just talking
to a camera in studio and you're trying
to stress out about memorizing that
first line Etc but your your uh your
stage presence really really matters for
anybody who's done speaking you can get
up on stage and say the exact same words
but if you don't have stage presence you
don't believe what you're saying at the
core of your being you're not going to
sway the audience it's the exact same
thing when you're talking to a camera
you're just talking to you're talking to
a bigger stage than you would at any
other stage but you don't see them and
so that makes it a little more
challenging so whether you can call
yourself out on it or if you've got
somebody on your team who's filming with
you who can say
hey uh that wasn't very good do it again
I remember when I recorded my audiobook
for for both built the server in your
one word I had two people in my ear my
producer who's looking at all the
technical stuff of like oh you know your
stomach rumbled or something
but again and then I had another
producer who was in LA who was more
paying attention to the tone
like hey Evan you read it perfectly but
there was no energy there like okay
thank you man do it again and I just
pick up from that line so the emotional
commitment like are you actually feeling
the words that you're saying as opposed
to just saying the words really really
really really matters once you get into
the teaching you'll be fine
I I very rarely meet somebody who signs
up for this program or other thought
leader experts trainers coaches I'm not
here to teach you how to teach for the
most part you guys do that great once
you get into the teaching you're fine
and you see that in the retention curves
like people are watching it's just that
beginning part and if we don't hook them
in at the beginning they're not going to
watch the rest of our teaching so
powerful opinion for a sentence second
sentence is context sentence like what
did you just say you just told me
something that doesn't make sense to me
you told me something that's challenging
one of my belief systems
so repeat it again in different words
make it make a little bit more sense and
then raise the stakes and raise the
stake says what happens to me if I don't
change this thing about myself if I
don't if I don't make this change by
watching this video this video is going
to teach you something that's going to
change my life I'm going to become a new
person at the end of this video right
that's the that's at least your
emotional state going in that's why
we're making this video to shift
somebody's belief system on something
that you know about
if I don't make that shift in this video
what happens
what happens to me if I stay stuck what
happens to me
your job as a thought leader is to give
perspective
it's not just this one-off little moment
that I'm struggling it's my entire life
and so that's your job is this one
little thing that people think they care
about they need to they need to have a
much broader view of how this is
impacting every area of their life and
if you fix that it becomes uh the
Cornerstone Habit to change everything
in your life right it's like oh my God I
thought I was just searching for a video
now I'm watching this person who's about
to change my whole life right so that's
that becomes your job
so powerful opinion context sentence
raise the stakes if you have to write
those down
those three sentences if you have to
record it 30 times until you get the
energy and the flow right it's worth it
because once you get through this and
you get into the teaching you'll be fine
I don't need you to do another take when
you're 20 minutes in and you're on point
number two of whatever your your
teaching is going to be but if you don't
nail the first three sentences film it
again and film it again and film it
again until until it you got the words
right and most importantly you got the
heart right
so uh here's Anna who uh a member of the
channel I don't I don't see her today
but Robert her husband is here on on the
stream so uh Robert can be taking notes
uh this is one of her videos trauma
bonding explained and YouTube has added
something relatively new for cards on
these um retention curves so if you ever
see an eye here you can click over and
it'll show you what's going on so she's
got three intro continue segment and dip
uh intro is going to be here in that
blue section continue segment is
probably going to be here and then the
dip is going to be at the end it'll give
you some date on it we're not super
focused on these other two segments
we're focused on what happens at the
beginning so if you hover over the eye
on this one it says 81 percent of
viewers were still watching at the 30
second mark this is higher than typical
compared to your other other recent
videos nicely done hey hey good job good
job Robert you guys are doing it
uh so we're looking at this video right
it's a 13 minute video trauma bonding
explained and I pulled okay well what is
she doing you know what what's happening
why is it so good so at the 118 Mark
she's still at 73 percent
118 into the video she's still at 73 so
this is a great video how does she start
the video
there's one kind of romantic
relationship that I wouldn't wish on
anyone and that's the kind that's been
made intense by a Chama Bond if you are
abused or neglected as a kid you've
probably been through it and I want to
help you make sure it never happens
again
right Robert's smiling hey she's doing a
good job she's doing a good job Robert
give her give her some props uh this is
great I mean it's four sentences instead
of three but it's still great so you
know we have a powerful opinion context
sentence raising mistakes
the only thing I would uh swap out here
is probably
it was one critique on here I would not
use the word probably at the beginning
of every video you don't want to hedge
this if you were abused or neglected as
a kid you've been through this
and if there is a hedge then you address
it later but we don't address the Hedge
at the beginning
and that's where you know van over here
to ask her well okay how many people
who've been neglected and abused as a
kid have not been through
this trauma
right it's probably some really low
percent
so don't hedge but everything else is
great and so she leads with a powerful
opinion she's hitting 73 at 118 into the
video uh YouTube's giving her props for
having such a great intro on it
and look how well the video is doing
right so this video is just over a month
old 40 whatever 43 days let's call it 20
000 views which is 5.5
000 more than usual
so the gray line is what a usual video
would do and here's how this video is
doing
so all in great job you know and then I
used to start her videos with with
something else it used to be hey I'm
Anna I'm the crappy childhood fairy on
and on and on she switched it to
powerful opinion and it's working
if you like sharing the success stories
as well
now I also pulled an old video from the
channel that didn't have uh the the
powerful intro and this one is about
meditation so one I mean the thumbnail
isn't as good uh you know it's an older
video so Robert we can go back and work
on that one uh but look what happens at
the beginning
you know just tanks why well look at
what's happening on this video it's the
typical
uh logo with music copy childhood fairy
right and boom instantly tanks
right so now this also this video also
talks about meditation that's the
promise how to meditate twice a day
something
um The Meditation doesn't actually start
until here
so this is where we need to match the
thumbnail and the title and the
beginning of the video because people
are skipping ahead to get to here
because they don't want to see on any of
this intro or uh then Anna starts
talking about meditation Etc this is
what I mean this is a 24 minute video so
this is at least three four minutes into
the video
five minutes maybe
um before something actually happens
that delivers on the promise so when you
see a curve that drops this drastically
there's something wrong with our intro
right so now we can't go back and fix
this
um but going forward it's a great
example of what is working and what is
not working for the channel
we're talking about something that I
haven't talked about inside of brand
Linux but but also just in general I
haven't really talked about ad
strategies yet and I think it's it's
interesting and helpful uh if you have
budget not everybody does when they're
starting their Channel but if you have
budget how can you use it to actually
grow your channel where a lot of people
do it incorrectly I can't tell you how
many accounts I've joined I've looked at
uh where they are just making a disaster
of their ad spend either one just going
completely off the books and not using
Google but using Reddit uh using other
kind of fake sources there's one guy big
big name guy who that was my first call
with him was like wow you're doing so
well look at your Channel Growing but
how come you're getting you're not
getting any stops oh like we just buy
a bunch of subs and views from Reddit
from Brazil
and then his channel got banned for a
week he's like okay never buy again from
Reddit you know I get that like the
metrics matter and the vanity matters
that you know I get all that but
but like if you're gonna buy views and
buy Subs let's do it in a way that's
actually kosher with with YouTube so
that's what I covered today I'm not
teaching any black cat stuff all of this
stuff is Google approved we're using
Google's own tools to be able to use it
and can really Propel your channel
forward
so I'm going to talk about the different
ad formats in stream versus Discovery so
in stream this is one of the big
mistakes a lot of people make
in stream are the ones that show up
before video usually and also sometimes
in the middle of the video or at the end
of the video
in-stream ads are great if you just want
to get views
think about it you're interrupting
somebody's video so this video this this
is a video that Russell Brunson put out
recently proximity Is Power uh talking
about human Tony Robbins when you click
play you see this before right so
there's two ads that will show up this
is the first one I want to watch Russell
Brunson and Tony Robbins but I'm getting
this ad for Dugout mugs you know I
probably don't care a lot about Dugout
mugs now these are great ads for
conversion
so you know Casey in the house I know
you're you're great at direct response
marketing uh if you have something to
sell
this is actually one of the most cost
effective and efficient ways right now a
lot of the people who are
Facebook ad gurus are moving to YouTube
because there's less restrictions and
it's getting a lot cheaper and these are
the ads that they're doing is this
pre-roll so if you have something to
sell you have a business model attached
to it whether you're running it before
your own videos one of the great reasons
of building an organic YouTube audience
is that then you can run pre-roll ads
against your own channel at a discounted
rate and then sell whatever program
you've got it's at a discounted rate
because you make money from the video as
well so you're paying to be on your own
channel but then you make the money back
on AdSense so if you've got something to
sell is fantastic
and every view anytime somebody goes
past the 15 second mark it counts as a
view
but it doesn't lead to organic growth
for the channel these guys are not going
to be subscribing to the channel so if
I'm sitting here I may watch this ad I
really want to get to this video I'm I'm
I may be trying to skip as soon as
possible but if I go past the 15 second
mark it counts as a view but there's no
place for me to actually subscribe to
Dugout mugs and I'm probably not going
to right because I want to watch this
video with Russell and Tony
so this is where a lot of people are
buying ads and it's just the wrong
method if you want growth for the
channel if you just want views if you
say hey it it's really important that I
get 10 000 views on each video the
cheapest possible right this is the way
to do it
but nobody's going to subscribe to the
channel
so it's just about balancing priorities
and I'm not here to judge you to say how
important views are for your for your
brand and everything else but it will
not help you grow the channel it is
fantastic for selling and pitching your
product the first five seconds of the
video is a pitch for the rest of the ad
because I can skip after five seconds so
you've got to hook me in the first five
seconds to make me want to watch the
rest of the ads and then go buy your
product so the options that I can do
here is learn more you know about about
whatever this program is get uh emotive
or skip the ad but nowhere can I
subscribe to it but this will count as a
view
okay not recommended for channel growth
though
Discovery is the other one okay so
that's called in stream the other is
Discovery those are your two options
in Discovery your ads are showing up as
a suggested View
so they're watching a video
most views you happen on mobile so this
is what it'll look like this is the
watch page you'll see a bunch of videos
underneath and then your ad will show up
right above all the other suggested
videos
this is what you want to be doing
the targeting becomes super important to
make sure you're targeting the Right
audience
but they're opting in to actually watch
the video
so I'm watching this video this was the
the if this was the same video this was
the Russell and Tony video I'm watching
it here underneath I see your video I
still have to click to go and watch it
so I'm opting in versus the the
in-stream ads where I'm being forced to
watch this commercial
so when you're getting a view it's much
more a real View and also leads to a
normal video page this page is leading
to a sales page it's leading me off-site
this page is leading me to a video but
then I can watch I can then subscribe
and so this is how we can get a lot of
Channel growth subscriber growth count
for our audience uh but the target
becomes super important because you can
get your video in front of a lot of
people it doesn't mean it's the right
people just like add buying across any
other platform
so we want to be going for Discovery if
you care about the channel growth so
this is just I need tons of views
but they're not going to ever be buyers
they're not going to subscribe to the
channel this is I care about getting
views and I want to grow my channel get
more subscribers
so I'm going to focus most of this talk
on Discovery we could dive in if you
have questions in the chat or at the end
about in-stream if you want to but
Discovery is how we're going to actually
grow a channel
so if you're if you're trying to create
a discovery campaign YouTube is Google
so you use Google AdWords when you're
creating a campaign
there are no campaigns that you can set
up yet that optimize for channel growth
AdWords was designed to be a conversion
sequence so if you see all the options
you can get sales leads website traffic
brand consideration Etc promote my app
local listings but there is no option
for YouTube subscriber growth
which actually creates an opportunity
because not a lot of people are doing it
so the cost is still relatively low to
be able to get in so we're going to
create a campaign without a goals
guidance and I'm just going to walk you
through kind of Step by Step so that if
you're super familiar with AdWords great
use it if you're not here's a
step-by-step sequence people to do it
next we're gonna go video
continue then we're going to go custom
video campaign
this one we would do for the in stream
if you wanted
a custom video campaign and then here
okay so some of the settings to pay
attention to
these settings can save you a lot of
money if you do it properly okay setting
number one always uncheck video Partners
on the Display Network these are all on
by default
always uncheck this all we care about if
we're trying to grow a channel is being
promoted on YouTube not across YouTubes
in Google's entire display Network other
websites Gmail
Etc we don't be showing up there we only
care about YouTube this one is Hit or
Miss search results
um if you really know your audience and
you really know the keywords that
they're going to be searching for this
means you're going to show up under
search or this one is going to show up
underneath somebody else's video
this is for sure a winner because
they're already watching videos this one
is a little iffy because
we want to not just be a utility Channel
where they're just searching and not
continuing the sequence we want them to
watch multiple videos from our Channel
so when you're showing up here they're
clicking on suggested
now we're bringing in the audience that
loves clicking on suggested videos so
they're more likely to watch another
video in another video in another video
where people who are only on search
don't necessarily always follow that
breadcrumb so you could play with it
this one's going to get you way better
results this one I would just test to
see if you're gonna do it really refine
your keywords and then pay attention to
if your channels are growing or not
location is a whole other discussion so
this is another one when I'm when I'm
talking to
um you know Drew works with clients I
end up just helping my friends who are
most of the biggest people in thought
leadership on YouTube
and when they're looking at growing
their channel the next question becomes
how much do you care about where they
come from
and this is different depending on the
person some people they just want to get
the hundred thousand the one million to
get the plaques to get the you know
prestige a little ego boost
um reputation and they don't care where
it's from
and so if you don't care where your
people coming from it's all countries
and territories
some people really want to build a list
of buyers like hey I want to I want to
sell my stuff to them eventually I want
to sell my subscriptions I want to sell
my consultant I want to sell my programs
courses Etc if you're doing that and
that's your goal then the four these are
the big four easy people go after
Australia Canada UK US those are the
people who have the most money who care
the most about personal development and
are most likely to buy your thing right
so how do you balance it and this is
there's no right answer there's some
people I've worked with it's like I
don't even care about buyers I have my
own business model I figured all that
out I just need for people when they go
to my YouTube channel they see big
numbers of real subscribers not like
fake subscribers that might get me
banned right it's like okay well this is
the way but just turn on all countries
and you'll get
a bunch of people from India and
Argentina and Brazil and Global but
you're not building a North America you
know Australia UK buyer list
um so there's no right answer just
what's the right answer for you and your
business for you right now some people
do a switch it's like okay once I get to
a hundred thousand then I'm gonna switch
over or once I get to a million then I'm
going to switch over because now I have
a little more Prestige because
especially if you've come from a
different industry
and you've had success and you're
starting on YouTube
you don't want to start and only have
800 subscribers so this is a faster way
to be able to walk into it
other settings always uncheck TV screens
always uncheck TV screens
because
you can get a lot of watch time on a TV
screen because it auto plays to the next
video so some people just leave their TV
on go do something else go to the park
whatever and your videos just keep
playing and playing and playing but to
subscribe from a TV screen is really
hard they have to get out their their
remote and click over it's just a really
big pain and so most people do not
subscribe from a TV screen so there's
another thing if we care about only
views TV screens are on if we care about
actually converting them to subscribers
growth for our Channel TV screens are
off the other three are all fine Peter's
saying it's cheaper to go everywhere is
there a country you've seen as cheapest
it'll be seven to ten times more
expensive
to Target these countries
seven to ten times more expensive
you don't care and you just want views
and subscribers and real people you just
you don't select certain countries you
just go all countries and territories
India will definitely be number one
just because they're so huge and
everybody's on YouTube there and they
all have their phones Etc then it'll
probably be Argentina Brazil South
American countries
um but it'll be seven or ten times more
so it's like of course I want these
countries of course but do you want to
pay seven to ten times more ooh okay
maybe not
so that becomes uh there's not again no
right or wrong answer it's just what
fits for your goals for the organization
and how how much do you prioritize
conversion versus just The Branding of
having X number of subscribers on your
channel okay so that's in-stream versus
Discovery right we want Discovery and
those are some of the settings to pay
attention to to help you save a lot of
money almost everybody gets this wrong
if I'm looking at somebody's campaign
they always have TV screens picked off
they sometimes have countries picked off
um they're making a lot of they they
almost always have these all three
clicked off and you're just basically
losing money
with those settings this will save you a
lot of money get you better results if
you want to see this full video as well
as trained live with me twice a month to
blow up your brand join the brand Linux
training program there's a link to join
right there next to me continue to
believe I'll see you there